last season on scream queens emma
roberts character chanelle was super
into her boyfriend chad
i want to be the one who tells you how
awesome you are all the time well uh you
had your chances off and you ruined it
but now season two is upon us and things
are a bit different in chanel's love
life emma teased what's to come during
her appearance on tuesday's watch what
happens live now taylor lautner and john
stamos are joining so that's very
exciting yeah any idea of either will be
your love interest
one of them is my love interest well i
think it's taylor lautner do you i do
interesting yeah because that would be
more kind of age-appropriate i don't
know if we always do things
appropriately over there but
uh but i i you'll have to you'll have to
see but honestly i would be happy
with either of them emma was joined on
the show by her nerve co-star dave
franco
now that the actress has worked with
both franco brothers dave and james it
begs the question who's the better
kisser here's what she told et on sunday
maybe i'll have to just kiss them both
again and then decide i'm not really
sure but by tuesday seems like emma had
made up her mind yeah davey
you